apercevoir dans ce sujet d'antoine fnaut
donner une conférence de presse cet
après-midi volodymyr rimouski qui une
nouvelle fois appelé bruxelles et
washington à faire davantage pour
soutenir son pays ce qui se passe en
ukraine aujourd'hui se passera en europe
demain voilà est-ce qu'il a notamment
déclaré le répondait aux questions cyril
payen l'écoutent
believe daté de western à chaque
communauté ce douanier nov tu supportes
you can't tu supportes your hands off to
be j'avais strong position ne gagnent
pas dire poutine
green a sur bruxelles l'ukraine
aujourd'hui tour reflète ce que les gens
libres dans le monde entier pense à la
façon dont nous combattons je pense à
tous les gens qui descendent dans les
rues ils y croient qu'il lutterait comme
cela lorsqu'il voit nos actions les
actions du gouvernement
les gens des autres pays pensent
que ils veulent que leur gouvernement se
comportant six ainsi répondre à votre
question 1
700 que les questions je pense que vous
savez vous-même que les gens qui
descendent dans les rues dans le monde
entier
descente pour une raison bien
particulière il pense que le monde doit
faire davantage ils pensent que le monde
ne fait pas assez
sinon grosse tous ces gens là oui son
gré des cendres et dans les rues pour
appeler nuire tous les gouvernements
tombent et on ne peut pas laisser
l'ukraine
tout seul abandonné
ce qui se passe
maintenant c'est que ce passera un et
robes de mariées et tous les gens
doivent se battre pour eux mais chez
nous comme ils peuvent
sur le front sud la ville d'odessa en
bordure de mer noire